two men have been convicted for their  role in conspiring to kidnap michigan  governor gretchen whitmer in 2020. the  court heard how adam fox and barry croft  jr plan to take the governor from her  vacation home and use explosive devices  to slow the police response they could  face up to life in prison two others  have already been convicted for the plot  which was intended to start a civil war  it all unraveled due to an fbi sting  operation in a statement governor  whitmer thanked prosecutors and said  that the verdicts prove that violence  and threats have no place in our  politics and those who seek to divide us  will be held accountable